let me ask you the big question
how for young people uh listening to
this today
in high school and college what advice
would you give them
in terms of uh which career path to take
and um maybe just about life in general
well in my case um i didn't start life
with any kind of goals
i was when i was going to college i was
like oh what did i say well maybe i'll
do electrical engineering stuff you know
um it wasn't like you know today you see
some of these young kids are so
motivated they're going to change the
world i was like
you know whatever and um
but then i did fall in love with
something besides my wife but i fell in
love
with this like oh my god it would be so
cool to understand how the brain works
and then i i said to myself that's the
most important thing i could work on
i i can't imagine anything more
important because if you understand how
brains work you build tells the machines
and they can figure out
all the other big questions of the world
right so and then i said i want to
understand how i work so i fell in love
with this idea and i became passionate
about it
and this is you know a trope people say
this but it was it's true
because i was passionate about it i was
able to put up
almost so much crap you know you know
i was i was in that you know i was that
person said you can't do this i was
i was a graduate student at berkeley
when they said you can't study this
problem
you know no one can solve this or you
can't get funded for it you know
then i went to do you know mobile
computing and it was like people say you
can't do that you can't build a cell
phone
you know so but all along i kept being
motivated because i wanted to work on
this problem i said i want to understand
the brain works and
i got myself male i've got one lifetime
i'm going to figure it out do the best i
can
so by having that because you know these
it's really as you point out lex it's
really hard to do these things people
it's just
there's so many downers along the way so
many ways
obstacles are getting your way yeah i'm
sitting here happy all the time but
trust me
it's not always like that that's i guess
the the happiness the the
the passion is a prerequisite for
surviving the whole
yeah i think so i think that's right um
and
so i i don't want to sit to someone and
say you know you need to find a passion
and do it no maybe you don't
but if you do find something you're
passionate about
then then you can follow it as far as
your passion will
let you put up with it do you remember
how you found it this is
how the spark happened
why specifically for me yeah like
because you said yeah such an
interesting
so like almost like later in life but
later i mean like not in
when you were five yeah you you didn't
really know
and then all of a sudden you fell in
love with that yeah yeah there was there
was
there's two separate events that
compounded one another one
when i was probably a teenager might
have been 17 or 18.
i made a list of the most interesting
problems i
could think of first was why does the
universe exist
it seems like not existing is more
likely yeah the second one was well
given exists why does it behave the way
it does you know it's laws of physics y
is equal to mc squared not mccubed you
know
attention question i don't know third
one was like what's the origin of life
um and the fourth one was what's
intelligence and i stopped there
i said well that's probably the most
interesting one and i put that aside
um as a teenager but then when i was 22
and i was reading the um no it was
excuse me i was 70 it was 1979 excuse me
i was reading uh so i was at that time i
was 22.
i was reading uh the september issue of
scientific american which is all about
the brain
and then the final essay was by francis
crick
who of dna fame and he had
taken his interest to studying the brain
now and he said you know
there's something wrong here he says we
got all this data
oh this fact this is 1979 all these
facts about the brain tons and tons of
facts about the brain
do we need more facts or do we just need
to think about a way of rearranging the
facts we have maybe we're just not
thinking about the problem correctly you
know
because he says this shouldn't be it
shouldn't be like this you know
so i read that and i said wow i said
i don't have to become like an
experimental neuroscientist i could just
look at all those facts and try and
become a theoretician and try to figure
it out
and i said that i felt like it was
something i would be good at
i said i wouldn't be a good
experimentalist i don't have the
patience for it
but i'm a good thinker and i love
puzzles
and this is like the biggest puzzle in
the world it's the biggest puzzle of all
time
and i got all the puzzle pieces in front
of me damn that was exciting
and there's something obviously you
can't convert towards they're just kind
of sparked
this passion and i have that a few times
in my life just something
um yeah just just like you uh
it grabs you yeah i thought it was
something that was both important
that i could make a contribution to yeah
and so all of a sudden it felt like oh
it gave me purpose in life
yeah you know i honestly don't think it
has to be as big as one of those four
questions
no no i think you can find those things
in in the smallest
oh absolutely i'm with uh david foster
wallace said like the key to life is to
be unborrowable i'm
i think i think it's very possible to
find that
intensity of joy in the smallest
absolutely i'm just you asked me my
story
yeah yeah i'm actually speaking to the
audience yeah it doesn't have to be
those four
you happen to get excited by one of the
bigger questions of
in the universe but uh but even the
smallest things and watching the
olympics now
just uh just giving yourself life uh
giving your life over to the study and
the mastery of a particular sport is
fascinating
and and uh if if it sparks joy and
passion you're able to in the case of
the olympics
basically suffer for like a couple of
decades to achieve i mean you can find
joint passion just being a parent i mean
yeah yeah the the parenting one is funny
so i always
um not always but for a long time wanted
kids and
get married and stuff and especially
that has to do with the fact that
i've seen a lot of people that i respect
get a whole other level of joy from kids
and you know at first is like
your thinking is well like i don't have
enough time in the day
right if i have this passion which is
true
yes but like if i want to solve
intelligence how's this kid
situation gonna help me but then you you
realize
that uh
you know like you said the things that
sparks joy and it's very possible that
kids can provide even a greater or
deeper more meaningful
joy than those bigger questions yeah
when they they enrich each other and
that that seemed like um
obviously when i was younger is probably
a counter-intuitive notion because
there's only so many hours in the day
but then life is finite and you have to
pick the things that give
give you joy yeah but you know also
you understand you you can be patient
too i mean it's finite
but we do have you know whatever 50
years or so it's not so long yeah
so so in my case you know in my case i
had to give up on my dream of the
neuroscience
because i i was a graduate student at
berkeley and they told me i couldn't do
this and i couldn't get funded and
you know and and so i went back in
and went back in the computing industry
for a number of years i thought it would
be four but it turned out to be more
but i said but i said i'll come back you
know i definitely i'm definitely going
to come back i know i'm going to do this
computer stuff for a while but i'm
definitely coming back everyone knows
that
and it's they moved like raising kids
well yeah you still you have to spend a
lot of time with your kids it's fun
enjoyable
um but that doesn't mean you have to
give up on other dreams it just means
that you
have to wait a week or two to work on
that next idea
you talked about the the the darker side
of me disappointing sides of human
nature that we're
hoping to overcome so that we don't
destroy ourselves i tend to
put a lot of value in um the broad
general concept of love
of uh the human capacity to
um of compassion towards each other
of just kindness whatever that longing
of like just the human
human to human connection yeah it
connects back to our initial discussion
i tend to
see a lot of value in this collective
intelligence aspect i think some of the
magic of human civilization
happens when there's uh a party is not
as fun when it you're alone yeah
i totally agree with you on these issues
yeah do you think
from my neurocortex perspective
what role does love play in the human
conditions uh well those are two
separate things from a new project's
kind of deal
i don't think it doesn't impact our
thinking about human uh about the
neocortex
from a human condition point of view i
think it's core um
i mean we get so much pleasure out of
loving people
and helping people um
so you know i can i'll rack it up to old
brain stuff and maybe you can throw it
under the
bust of evolution if you want um that's
fine
um it doesn't impact how i think about
how we model the world
but from a humanity point of view i
think it's essential well i tend to
give it to the new brain and also i tend
to think that some of aspects
of that need to be engineered into ai
systems
both in their ability to have compassion
for other humans
and their ability to
maximize love in the world between
humans
so i'm more thinking about the social
networks so like
whenever there's a deep integration
between ai systems and humans
so specific applications where it's uh
ai and humans
i think that's something that often not
talked about in terms of um
metrics over which you try to maximize
uh like which metric to maximize in a
system
it seems like one of the most powerful
things in societies
is the capacity to work it's fascinating
i think it's
it's a great way of thinking about it
you know i have
i have been thinking more of these
fundamental mechanisms in the brain as
opposed to
the social interaction between the
interaction between humans and ai
systems in the future which is
and i think if you think about that
you're absolutely right um
but that's that's a complex system i can
have intelligent systems that don't have
that
component but they're not interacting
with people you know they're just
running something or building a
building someplace or something i don't
know um
but if you think about interacting with
humans yeah it's it's gonna
and then but it has to be engineered in
there i don't think it's gonna appear on
its own
that's a good question i yeah well we
could
in terms of uh uh from a reinforcement
learning perspective
whether the darker sides of human nature
or the better angels of our nature
uh win out yeah statistically speaking i
don't know
i tend to be optimistic and hope that
love wins out in the end
um you've done a lot of incredible stuff
uh
and your book is uh
driving towards this fourth question
that you started with
on the nature of intelligence what do
you hope your
legacy for people reading a hundred
years from now
how do you hope they remember your work
how do you hope they remember this book
well i think as an entrepreneur or
scientist
or any human who's trying to accomplish
some things
i have a view that really all you can do
is accelerate the inevitable um
it's like you know if we didn't figure
out if we didn't study the brain someone
else would start the brain if you know
if feline just
didn't make electric cars someone else
would do it eventually and if you know
if thomas edison didn't invent a light
bulb we wouldn't be using candles today
so what you can do as an individual is
you can accelerate
something that's beneficial and make it
happen sooner than whatever that's
that's really it that's all you can do
um you can't create a new reality that
it wasn't gonna happen
um so from that perspective
um i would hope that our work not just
me but our work in general
um people would look back and said hey
they really helped make this better
future happen sooner
um they you know they helped us
understand the nature of false beliefs
sooner than we met up they made
we now we're so happy that we have these
intelligent machines doing these things
helping us
that that maybe that solved the climate
change problem and
they made it happen sooner so i think
that's the best
i would hope for some would say those
guys just
moved the needle forward a little bit in
time well
i do it it feels like the progress of
human civilization is not
is uh there's a lot of trajectories and
if you have individuals that accelerate
towards one direction that helps steer
human civilization so
i think in this long stretch of time all
all trajectories will be traveled but i
think it's nice
for this particular civilization on
earth to travel down one that's not yeah
well i think you're right i mean look we
have
to take the whole period of you know
world war ii nazism or something like
that well that was a bad sidestep right
we've been over there for a while but
you know there is the optimistic view
about life that
um that ultimately it does converge in a
positive way
it progresses ultimately even if we have
years of
darkness um so yeah so i think you could
perhaps
that's accelerating the positive it
could also mean eliminating some bad
missteps along the way too um
but but i i'm an optimistic in that way
i was like you know despite
we talked about the end of civilization
you know i i think
we're going to live for a long time i
hope we are um i think our society in
the future is going to be better we're
going to have less discord we're gonna
have less people killing each other you
know we'll solve you know we'll make the
they'll live in some sort of way that's
compatible with the carrying capacity of
the earth
um i'm optimistic these things will
happen uh and all we can do is try to
get there sooner
and at the very least if we do destroy
ourselves we'll have a few satellites
that will uh that will tell alien
civilization that we
were once or maybe our future you know
future inhabitants of earth you know
imagine we you know
the planet of the apes scenario you know
we kill ourselves in a you know million
years from now or billion years from now
there's another species on the planet
curious creatures were once here yeah um
jeff thank you so much for your work
and um thank you so much for talking to
me once again well actually it's great i
love what you do i love your podcast you
have the most interesting people
me aside so
it's a real service i think you do for
uh a very broader sense for humanity i
think
thanks jeff all right pleasure
you